few heroes in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe have been as fun to follow over
the years as the Hulk from his perpetual
inner conflict to his temper nearly
limitless strength and near
invincibility the character has plotted
a uniquely absorbing story that view of
his fellow heroes can match here's his
story in full while you can find the
beginning for most MCU heroes simply by
heading back to their origin stories the
earliest moments of the Hulk's timeline
are a little harder to pin down the
problem is Hulk technically doesn't have
an MCU origin story like he does in
other movies not in detail anyway in
fact his story begins several years
after the other guy already came into
existence however over time and through
hints exposition and flashbacks it
becomes clear that banner originally
volunteered to test his own gamma
radiation experiments on himself and
things quickly went very wrong the
experiment led to the creation of the
Hulk a being that's in simplistic terms
shares a body and mind with Bruce Banner
although for many years only one could
express themselves at any one time not
long after the accident the duo find
themselves on the lam these early years
erupted for banner who was constantly
tracked by the US Army he struggles to
contain the Hulk in order to stay quiet
and out of sight after several years of
moving around the scientist finds
himself living a secret life as a
fugitive in Brazil where he focuses on
anger management and searches for ways
to reverse his condition by 2008 Banner
has spent nearly half a year in hiding
in Brazil where he works in a bottling
Factory however his tenuous situation is
upended when general Thunderbolt Ross
finally tracks him down
when this happens he transforms into the
Hulk blows his cover and goes back on
the run the ensuing adventure sees
banner returned to America where he
reunites with his sweetheart the
generals daughter Betty Ross and
continues his quest to heal himself of
his condition throughout these events
he's closely dogged by general Ross's
forces and even meets them head-on in
front of Culver University where he is
directly confronted by Emil Blonsky a
British special ops commando injected
with the super soldier serum that allows
him to survive his first encounter with
the Hulk after that Blonsky escalates
the situation by having the Hulk's blood
transfused into his own body an event
that turns him into the
hulk-sized villain abomination meanwhile
banner realizes the futility of trying
to fix his condition and is finally
taken into custody by general Ross just
in time for abomination to appear on the
scene this new threat forces Ross to
release banner as it quickly becomes
apparent that Hulk is the only hope they
have to contain the transform Blonsky
this leads to a catastrophic showdown in
Harlem where abomination is subdued and
Hulk flees the scene after the events of
Harlem it seems apparent that the
scientist may finally be gaining a level
of control over his angry or other half
however by the time he reinterred the
larger MCU story much of that progress
has been lost and the scientist is once
again living a quiet life of solitude
this time hiding in India and helping
the local population it's here that
Black Widow pays him a visit in 2012
asking him to lend his impressive
scientific knowledge to shield in its
attempt to find the tesseract and
protect the world from a global threat
banner reluctantly agrees and soon finds
himself working alongside the crew that
will soon be known to the world as the
Avengers although banner joins the team
with good intentions it doesn't take
long for the Hulk to show up and
threaten the entire operation after a
tussle with Thor that almost destroys
shields Helicarrier
Hulk ends up falling out of the sky
before turning back into banner on the
ground from there he's given a helping
hand by a security guard who lends him
his motorcycle so he can reunite with
the team when banner reunites with the
Avengers they're in the early stages of
fending off an invasion of Chitauri
soldiers on the streets of New York City
as he heads into battle he reveals the
one thing that has taught him how to
willingly control his transformations
into the Hulk
that's my secret captain
I'm always angry
Oh Hulk plays a central role in the
ensuing Battle of New York Smashing
Chitauri stop in to Leviathan or two and
even giving Loki a particularly brutal
smackdown in stark tower after the
battle banner finds and he no longer
needs to live perpetually in fear of
arrest and settles into a new phase of a
superhero career at one point he even
attempts to help Tony Stark process some
of the reformed Playboy's own traumatic
experiences you actively napping I was I
drifted over the next few years banner
and Hulk continued to work with the
Avengers albeit sin two very different
capacities banner as the brains and Hulk
is the Brawn prior to the Battle of
sokovia banner continues to offer the
Avengers his incredible intellect as a
scientist he helps Tony Stark work on
combining Baron von strucker's work with
the Ultron program inadvertently
creating Ultron in the process he also
helps create vision and even strikes up
a romantic spark with Natasha Romanoff
Hulk on the other hand is repeatedly
brought out to save the day when the
team is in a tight spot this begins with
the retrieval of Loki's scepter from von
strucker's base in sokovia and ends with
the world-saving showdown with ultron in
the same location in the interim he also
duels Iron Man in Johannesburg
reinforcing the troubling truth that the
Green Machine is little more than an
unwieldy tool in the hands of his fellow
Avengers once Ultron is defeated the
Hulk refuses to surrender control back
to banner instead taking the Avengers
quinjets and flying off into the unknown
after the events of sokovia Hulk's story
takes a rather dramatic turn while
flying the Quinjet through space hulk
enters a wormhole and suddenly finds
himself crash landing on the strange
garbage planet known as Sekar once there
his powerful physique and fighting
prowess catches the attention of the
Grandmaster who recruits him as one of
his gladiators a position uniquely
suited to Hulk's violence-prone
temperament Hulk remains in control for
the next two earth years it isn't until
2017 that the cover is finally blown on
his self-imposed exile when he finds
himself confronted in gladitoria
continues
we must prevent Ragnarok learn the
prophesied death of my home world the
end of days it's the end of it while
Hulk has no desire to leave his comfy
situation he does show Thor where the
Quinn jet landed which inadvertently
exposes him to her reporting a black
widow and allows banner to regain
control of his mind once banner is back
he and Thor joined Valkyrie and Loki to
form the revenger x' and head back to
Asgard their banner and Hulk help Thor
stop his bill and his sister hella by
unleashing Ragnarok during the fight
hope fearlessly dispatches Hellas giant
wolf Fenris and then jumps right into
the maw of the fire researcher while the
monster is in the middle of destroying
Asgard afterward bulk joins the
surviving ask guardians as they evacuate
onto a spaceship just in time to escape
ass carts destruction with Thor's home
reduced to atoms behind them they set a
course for Earth only to be interrupted
by Thanos who destroys the ship and
kills most of the passengers when Hulk
attempts to stop him
the mad Titan decisively wins their
fights with a few well-placed blows and
Hulk is only saved from death when
Heimdall summons the Bifrost then sends
him hurtling back to earth this
disastrous confrontation is the final
straw for home who refuses to help the
Avengers in the ensuing conflict with
Thanos and his armies instead banner is
left to do his level best with Tony
Stark's Hulkbuster armor while Hulk's
absence comes across as cowardice on the
surface his motivation is at least
partly fueled by the fact that he
refuses to be taken advantage of by the
Avengers all over again Hulk's absence
from the first round of the war against
Thanos serves as a crisis point for the
hero and while it initially has
catastrophic consequences it ultimately
leads banner to the next step in his
story's evolution during the 5 years
after that osnaps away half of the
universe banner and Hulk finally
confront one another in an attempt to
find some kind of middle ground the
results Professor Hulk
realizing that he needs to stop seeing
Hulk is a problem banner decides to
embrace his alter-ego as the cure to his
maladies he dives back into his long
dormant gamma radiation research and
spends 18 months in a lab using his own
consciousness and intellect with Hulk's
physical prowess this new round of
experiments officially brings the
two-sided character together into one
personality for the first
time in the MCU the arrival of Professor
bulk ends up transforming not only the
character but also its role within the
MCU the cerebral yet muscle-bound hero
finds a new lease on life by the time
2023 rolls around as he helps the
Avengers turn back the clock and undo
the damage of Thanos to snap first he's
brought in by Captain America Black
Widow and ant-man to help figure out
time travel during Tony Stark's
temporary retirement while that
experiment ends up a flop it doesn't
change the fact that the green skinned
Avenger still knows enough to properly
and concisely explain how time travel in
the MCU works if you travel to the past
that pass becomes your future and your
former present becomes the past which
can't now be changed by your new future
next he travels back to New York City in
2012 where he's faced with the
embarrassment of encountering his past
self from there he's able to find the
ancient one and convince her to
surrender her most prized possession the
time stone after the team has traveled
through time and gathered the six
Infinity stones they returned to the
Avengers headquarters in upstate New
York in order to officially assemble
starts version of the Infinity Gauntlet
once that gauntlet is complete though
one question remains who will put it on
and snap their fingers let me do
something goodness ultimately it's Hulk
who steps up declaring that his
resilience the gamma radiation makes him
the perfect candidate for the job
he dons the gauntlets and snaps his
fingers restoring half of the universe
in an instant and causing permanent
damage to his arm in the process
this move is indicative of how far the
character has come since those early
days of inner turmoil hot tempers and
childish behavior at the end of the day
it's Hulk that makes the sacrifice play
and brings back half of the universe in
the process while his arm took some
serious damage from undoing Thanos to
snap
Hulk is hardly down for the count on the
contrary
Hulk is one of the only original
Avengers still standing post endgame
which means his future in the MCU is
wide open not only is he in an excellent
place as far as his personal story arc
goes but he's also a character that has
spent time on and off earth which means
he could join with anyone from
spider-man in the Big Apple to Captain
Marvel anjala or even the guardians of
the galaxy as they search for Gamora
according to cheat sheet bulk actor Mark
Ruffalo is still under contract to
appear in two more MCU films although
they likely won't be standalone outings
due to universals claim on solo movies
for the character still don't go
assuming you've seen the last of the big
guy just yet he's still got a few fights
left in him check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]